[Music]
foreign
podcasts we have the guy that Brian wish
he's met six years ago I made a podcast
with wait fantastic Tabby thank you guys
thank you thank you in the building
that's right that's right what a second
what does it feel to be at the table no
you know I remember the first video I've
seen you were ticking things up we'd
said and all that no yeah that's great I
love it they Ambush me I know what I'm
about to get into now they're like oh
yeah no it's awesome man I'm glad to be
here we had a blast last night right oh
my God what an event what a time man
question when do child protection laws
come into this sort of thing for what
those fights happened like yeah because
they were just two how old swarms like
uh
yeah yeah uh but the other guy he didn't
fight like a grown man but he tried I'll
give him that he tried his best it was
those punches what about the spins
though you got to rate the spins yeah he
was some NBA level spinning going on I
mean bro that guy was going to the rim
do you think it uh I rated that he lost
so much weight but I also thought you
can't learn boxing and lose that weight
at the same time
yeah I mean you can't learn boxing in
two weeks I think that looking back at
it and as I as I said on commentary it
was
when I heard this fight was announced I
was very skeptical I the the words I
heard was he would be Alex Wassabi I
think we can all categorically say right
now he couldn't beat an egg right now no
and to be fair to uh I want to say this
if
if JJ was the one with two weeks notice
yeah and this guy uh swarms I'd had four
years or whatever JJ's had the result
would be the same but it's flipped you
know what I mean it would it it's this
is what happens when you get a guy with
loads of experience a guy with no
experience like yeah and that's not what
boxing is about
um also by the way it goes the other way
as well so you're talking about his past
I think it goes into the future that you
can flip it he has no ambition to be in
this either so there is not really the
same hunger and fight that is gonna
happen no bro let's just call it this
guy's never stepping in a rig again he's
never had another experience like this I
hope he does though can I just say it
because I agree it'll never be that bad
again right he's had a baptism of fire
and 40 000 people there for your first
ever fight again there with a guy who
knows exactly what he's doing but he can
talk the talk promote so I do think
there's potential there but the the
problem was my first thought was okay we
got fousey yeah we got uh for his temper
who didn't have an opponent point we had
slim we had sold puppy I was like why
wasn't one of these guys chosen instead
for the main event and now when you see
the great performances by a lot of these
yeah you know that the test that we
wanted for JJ it was there which wasn't
an acid test which wasn't a Jake Paul
and Fast Track and all of this sort of
army Fury but a reasonable test to gauge
by JJ is the problem is we're 24 hours
on now we have no clue how good JJ is
it's really hard to tell it's really
hard to tell from the last three years
to now what the improvements are yeah
it's a hot night through butter every
time and having said that did we learn
anything about what do we what do we
actually see him do in the ring because
to me I'm not going to look good
unfortunately and that's the problem is
that's another thing did he look good
like yeah kind of but it's hard to look
good good when the other guy is running
away from the entirety it's hard to
catch him before you're trying to pin a
milestone yeah you know there's a car
yeah you know it's when the other guy is
throwing at you you're actually more
likely to land and to to show what you
know I've sold puppy yeah if you engage
yeah yeah the problem with kids I mean
one thing we did learn he's in freakish
shape we knew this kind of but to have
two fights one night to be able to cool
down your motor right to bring that
Adrenaline Rush all the way back down
lose all that momentum get back in the
locker room have to rest and then build
it right back up again that's tough to
do and I know it's not can I ask yeah do
you actually think he was do you think
there was any trepidation from JJ
because you you guys have both been
around him I didn't see the same
fear or fighting face that we saw in the
past from KSI oh this was a walk in the
past and that's not yeah and that's not
a critique from me no it but I think
when you want to become an athlete
when you say not trepidation but
frustration right there was a moment
where he was like I can't quite get my
hands on this guy it wasn't all there he
didn't put it together the way he wanted
to and I know he's used to Sparrow
people and I know that's not it
necessarily his fault because dudes were
doing 360s in the middle of the ring and
and pineda's taking a knee and then
popping up and you know there's a lot of
stuff going on in case I just wants to
get it done let's just you know get it
banged on let's go forward but what I
will say was when the first time I
interviewed him in the first part of the
night he was ready to go switched on and
the second same thing but I don't think
it was ever going to be KSI feeling
trepidation versus the opponent it was
just him versus himself right it was him
being able to handle that moment handle
all the expectation all of the build to
this thing and then go out and put on
that performance for however many twenty
thousand Thirty forty thousand people so
for me this felt more about a a soft
launch for a boxing company yeah or a
boxing series that are going to happen
and I get it a very soft launch the
thing is the thing is I actually think
there are a lot of there are a lot of
pluses on the night right like I was in
there oh my God for a little while sure
I didn't have a seat but I was in there
for a little while
because we Logan and uh his team just
came in here and I was saying like just
missed him right
um
we were having a similar conversation uh
with similar problem uh that each other
had on the night which was like I'm like
okay I'm presenting I'm commentating I
asked for 10 tickets for my friends the
kickoff boys all of that yeah one of
them traveled for two hours as you get
there so you're like these [__]
tickets about to be there by the way
because I've told my friends yeah and
I'm thinking
I'm a big part of the show not that I'm
the big name or anything like that and
I'm not acting like I'm right Diva but
the the least I would expect because I
didn't do this for money I Did It For
The Experience yeah enjoyment same as I
always have
no tickets
was [__] over uh didn't have a problem
so what happened well so we have a
little crew and geo geo and um his
girlfriend turn up a little bit earlier
so we had the behind the sit behind the
camera crew yeah Brian's looking after
everyone this wasn't just a brand deal
so we we we tend they turned up there
they turned up a little bit earlier than
us took three tickets easy just go over
to the side bit great we were like okay
awesome so we get there there's about
three different places giving out
tickets big big long line of people
there's clearly an influencer area I
think I bake it never couldn't get his
tickets either nor could uh Reeve and
those kind of Burnham theobic uh like
this is one of The Originals the reason
yeah so he deserves to be there so yeah
like yeah he's uh he's an originator
yeah so anyway
Brian's name uh no maybe it's under true
Geordie maybe it's Lawrence McKenna
maybe it's this maybe it's that every
time maybe it's under real Geordie not
as Todd kept going I told him at one
point I was sitting rings I heard you
and so we we get no tickets so in the
end the woman goes look the reality is
I've already given you tickets to
someone else uh your ticket these are
your numbers I'll write down these
numbers I'm just going to give you any
ticket you go scan it walk in go into
the middle find it ringside yeah and you
guys can check right so a triangle
ringside can't go ringside the guy goes
with all due respect there are a lot of
YouTubers here tonight you could be
anyone I was like this is a great night
the funniest part of that is the guy
says that to me and then someone goes
Laura's can I get a picture please and I
was like yeah of course bro of course
and I just look at the guy like of
course this is what normal people do
every day we just take pictures of a
randoms so then we get we get down
ringside there's a guy sitting in the
seats right and uh the security calls
him out and they go you know uh what's
going on here and he goes listen man I
paid twenty thousand dollars for these
tickets to be in these seats and then he
goes Anthony Joshua's ringside tickets
don't even cost that you know he's
talking [__] yeah literally he goes and
my grandma's here so I was like what
bring your granny so I look at a huge
KSI function yeah six year old woman
sitting there and I literally look at
security and I go I'm not moving that
woman I'm not [__] moving yeah and I
just went I give up and I just and the
guy was like oh we'll see what we can do
no one did anything like it was just a
complete waste of time so for Logan so I
thought that this would have been like a
oh maybe it's it's a me thing you know
maybe right didn't care about me Logan
was like nah same [__] I'm not sure what
same [__] yes they didn't get anything
they basically allowed Logan and a
couple of his guys yeah because he's
Logan and everyone knows who he is but
even they were [__] over so in terms
of organizing and looking after people
definitely like I'll give an example
that was like six o'clock and I was in
my pants and then I get a message saying
like yeah I think you're uh wanted
downstairs I'm like I don't know am I
you know so I definitely think that
there's um improvements however what I
will I do want to say not all negative
the production in terms of the way the
show looks amazing was it Immaculate the
sound the the level of quality
throughout was was I mean the entrances
it was all amazing and to see that we've
come from the copper box and I mean
there won't be talking times uh it's
improved a lot so it's not all I think
the zone are a great place for this to
happen yeah and it is the first one
right but like you know I heard there
was an after party I'm like oh right
great so yeah let's get oh all right us
not for not for me then because I'm only
presenting the show them having said
that the sound was great and that sounds
yeah the sound was good and I'll say
this when I was like I this is my my
first one right and so for me I'm just
where do you need me I'll do whatever I
need to do you did a great job I
appreciate that I really wonder by the
way I did I really wanted you on uh
commentary as the play-by-player guy
nothing against Todd uh because Todd was
great and actually Todd was a man having
experienced heads there was great but I
did I made no I mean you were there in
the production meeting I said I want me
and weird to commentator yes you know
not in a nice way and then like on the
morning of it's like oh by the way Chris
Eubanks uh working with you guys as well
yeah nothing against Chris as well but I
was like Chris Eubank Jr or Chris uh
junior oh yeah yeah yeah I thought we
had a legend in the building I I I
actually I'd actually said to Chris when
I met one all right Chris Owen uh
interviewed your dad once I went uh
asked him a lot of boxing questions just
talked about Sunday school for two hours
and like he he didn't know I could say
you didn't know how to take me yeah but
over the night you warmed up to me yeah
we had a bit of a laugh to be fair
um but yeah it was just a bit
I thought because it was with the Zone
we'd be a bit more uh fleshed out yeah
planned out I didn't think things would
be as last minute at times as they were
however hopefully it came off all right
you know what I mean what I really liked
about it is what JJ also attached to it
in the press conference you did though
because those kind of things can be a
little bit flat sometimes right yeah
where you've got to ask these corporate
questions and go in the top Corner yeah
that was top top left corner yeah yeah
as as the uh the moderate are always his
top top as far away from everyone as
possible possible next to deji I'll just
give it it's a good thing I have a long
neck because you're right you crane that
around yeah right so you nailed that by
the way but with that you you I think JJ
did deliver a good message this about it
is about the people who are taking part
and very often I think people can forget
that like behind the scenes it can be a
bit like let's cream off as much as we
can here let's just like get any event
out there doesn't matter if the people
get paid this is kind of the start of
something I think it is good broadly
it's good I'll be honest if if every
experience against was like that I don't
know how many of them I would want to do
because yeah there was a moment in that
in the night where I was like yeah I
think this is my last one like please do
it again you will do it again I love the
fights me ringside talking about the
fight that's what it's about that's my
happy place yeah but it was the other
stuff all right I was like in the hotel
in your pants
in the pants yeah yeah in the punts yeah
I think I think you should do it again
because I think once you do it a couple
more times I think you've got a taste
for it and you're sort of I do love it
yeah I don't know if it loves me though
I had a lot of backlash on social media
all right what can I think what are we
talking about well there's an old suck
my nuts spot yeah
um who's this guy in that that suit it
was just like Jordy knows nothing the
idea I'm like you do know like I was
gonna say a brick proper boxing down
people I think people like I'll take
this before because people look at me as
like some savant in in boxing and and
mixed martial arts but yeah pick
yourself up sure yeah I know you know
that's what I do he has been doing this
and doing it more accurately than
sometimes I or anyone else does even I
remember back to the sometimes I
remember back to the Connor and Dustin
talks where was it the UFC or BT Sport
brought you one yeah
he was spot on with everything he said
and the guys that are in the room that
are supposed to be paid to do this and
nothing against them weren't and he had
it from five six months beforehand and
he saw it before anyone else did and he
saw it many times before and I get I you
know I have a look and I have a way
about me that sort of Rose people
sometimes you know not not necessarily a
lovely way about it but you know what I
think it is and I get it like um I
actually think a lot of these events uh
Miss and this is a problem in most
influencer stuff at the moment they want
it to go off without a hitch so they
want these kind of engineered moments of
uh like uh they call it false Jeopardy
right but they want these engineered
moments of JJ's coming to the ring
something's gonna happen here
and the same happens with UFC and
anything else where those people have
got too much investment in the
influencer so they can't say what's
really going on but it makes it plain
and boring so you need someone in the
room the catfish to keep nipping away at
people that was the one thing I felt
when we had the production meetings was
I was like hmm ultimately and this is no
disrespect to anyone in those meetings
because they're all professionals and
doing professional boxing but what I
thought was I creatively I'd love to
have more of an input in because it's
it's sort of like to take the weigh-in
show for example there's this camera
like there's this kooky well that'll be
wacky because this is what all the kids
are doing you know and when you realize
the age difference between the people on
camera and the people behind camera yeah
disowned like to put themselves across
as a bit of a Forward Thinking yeah sure
yeah game changers at your hand side
right and when you actually look at the
behind the scenes that's where you
realize well
if you want to change the game you need
to bring in some young fresh new ideas
yeah and I think that that would do them
the world of good not just for the
influencer boxing events but all of
their stuff because they do seem to want
to move in that direction I mean look at
me but is it a tagline not me where
reality is you're still using the old
white guys you know what I mean don't
put yourself down like that North End uh
no offense um but no I
I'm giving them credit but I'm also
saying what I think could be done better
yeah and ultimately
that's what a Skies forward Sky could
never do this Sky you're so set in their
ways yeah yeah sky are so behind the
times so I've got to give those Own
Credit as the Forward Thinking brand but
I'm just like yeah but keep going in
that direction keep pushing it yeah yeah
and I think hopefully they'll learn a
lot from this one yeah no like I said it
was my first one
um I I everyone that I worked with and
and you know the people that helped us
behind the scenes could we just say on
the day of we thought Wade was doing the
in-ring interviews yeah
and then the day of it was like actually
no you're not you're just backstage all
night and I was so disappointed for you
yeah because yeah I wanted you to either
be commentating or in the ring and I
just felt like that's not where it
belongs to you who sorry who so who did
end up commentating and then doing the
amazing it was me but but and I'm
privileged to do that I'm not gonna no
but I'm not complaining but oh I've got
got it for you mate got it who would be
doing those because I am going to need
to I think I've done that before so I do
hey I had words back in the meeting he
did yeah he knows that yeah yeah Brian
came in and laid the law down but right
no everybody that I worked with I was so
grateful for I'm not gonna name their
names they know who they are but I I
took it as a learning experience for
myself you know and I got to I just try
to soak up everything because you know
we work in the content side in that side
we know very well right to the point
where we can out talk and and really
just put information that they just
don't know out on people but on the
professional side and on the on the the
side that I really want to delve into
more I'm just soaking up little things
here and there seeing what works and
seeing what doesn't even backstage I
don't even know if you guys got all the
packages we did prereq interviews with
everybody and I don't think they they
you know filmed them all or they put
them out all but I was dragging my PA
around and just like hey we gotta go get
fousey we gotta get deji we gotta go get
Kenny that was one pre event interview
that has gone semi-viral between uh Joe
Weller oh oh yeah the manager the KSI
mom's Taylor moms who all of a sudden
like six months ago she didn't know who
he is now he's challenging Joe Walla to
get in the boxing ring with him no no
not even that he was challenging Joella
and this is one of my
that
whole exchange was odd yeah
um and I thought
it's
I thought myself if you were my manager
would I want you threatening or like I I
I I thought you know you maybe you
should just be let the YouTubers do the
YouTube thing I understand you love JJ
he's your guy everything you business
partner right listen protective yeah but
you have to understand that there's a
game going on here and your role in that
game is not to get in the game right you
know what I mean and I I felt like Joe
was doing what Joe should be doing
and making the if anything helping Saudi
I was gonna say Joe could have been and
maybe still is could be a player in this
thing yeah I think I think all I'm
saying is like I'm not uh saying mom's
uh did anything crazy but I think when
he looks back at it as a older manual
gun I probably should have just left
that yeah that one was probably a
missing yeah Joe starts patting him on
the shoulder yeah Joe won that
confrontation I mean I don't have any
vested interest in this so I can say it
but I think Joe won the confrontation
because Joe understood the rules of the
exchange I don't think mum's fully
understood well mum's said something
like or I will he sort of started a
threaten John and that's when Joe was
like I got you yeah right no and that's
the thing like Joe's well-versed in that
and he does beef he does beef he does
YouTube good at it and I love mams and I
appreciate the opportunity to be a part
of his own but that yeah I think he'll
look back and say I was a misstep like I
say there's a lot of learning going on
again
when I had a little chat with him he
said the last three months I've been
living yeah I was telling him too I was
like the fight game is mad yeah this is
that first time they have a main event
pull out on your first big event that's
a pain in the ass and then we keep it
together fair play to them you know
going and finding guys and yes it wasn't
the level that we're looking for for JJ
can we talk about pinata yeah I thought
it was so weird it was uh for a pro to
get in there and that's why when they
were like talking about oh he's a pro
box I was like no like just like just no
um yeah let me talk about the press
conference before and the weigh-in yeah
yeah and by that what I mean is
uh why did he put the sunglasses on and
also why you know you know a real boxer
honestly I get it but it felt very much
I felt like he was ready for his high
school uh yeah like yearbook thing or
like his graduation yeah when he had
that Blazers
the whole here's the thing he's
obviously not a rich guy though exactly
I was gonna say yeah here's the thing
you probably you know again on a very
short notice I mean I know from from
behind the scenes work they were just
trying to get him to get a picture for
the passport so they get him it was that
close right they didn't have a passport
well he was just trying to get
everything done right pictures they're
like oh we gotta get you know stuff done
really quickly and so this guy out of
his element completely and again not in
this scene at all has no idea who KSI is
even said so he's like I've never heard
of him I have no idea so he's doing his
best but it was definitely a guy that
was just completely over out of his
scene like he had no idea where he was
at and what he was doing did either of
you get any insight to how The
Replacements were chosen through working
with these guys no I mean listen you
it's tough to know it feels like they
put their hand in a bucket and just yeah
right it feels like they literally rip
the Yellow Pages up and then just pick
the first phone number out of it like
stop I'm trying to work that stuff I
don't I don't exactly know
um I just know that every the way that
things were done at least what it looked
like for me was who do we know that's
either one that needs an opportunity can
accept it quickly and can give some
legitimacy to it and that was why I
think Pineda was around the legitimate
side of it the pro boxing side and of
course I don't think anybody's saying
this from that side from the back end
but I think everyone knows that was a a
storyline power move right JJ gets the
first pro boxer regardless of the talent
level skill the name the label pro boxer
before Jake does that was the idea in my
mind for them the marketing Ploy from
them now but can I ask then when will
you see him in the ring and you see he
is clearly not acting like a pro boxer
that's the thing he was grimacing every
time he got touched in anywhere yeah
it worked up until the fight started
right as far as like this is the pro
boxer this is this you know I'm fighting
a pro before Jake is right but then you
go and you if you want to break it down
skill for skill talent for talent Tyron
Woodley eats that kid alive right like
absolutely I mean it doesn't go past get
those as well but yeah I mean we could
go down the list of Jake opponents that
that would you know have their way with
that guy but keeps on the undercard of
that oh yeah there's a lot of guys on
the undercard that would have had their
way yeah he wasn't good and it's not and
it's not his fault right like the guy
again pulled out of his element did what
he's supposed to do but I don't know
what was going on with the taking the
knee and he was complaining a lot with
shots behind the head and JD does swing
wild sometimes in Fair Play but he was a
long ways a lot most of them weren't on
the back of the head though points where
he was getting body shot and he was
looking at the referee like are you
gonna let him do that to me and I'm like
do you know what pro boxing is I thought
you there was a point where he was
stopping it and saw the reference with
the body shot and he looked at the ref
and then took a knee the referee was
explaining to him I was like me this is
over yeah he's quit yeah like he quit
multiple times in there and the ref by
the way the referees were terrible it
was a it was a very up and down scale
because there were some very quick like
diving in front of guys for standing
Gates and then there were somewhere like
like in the main event where the Refuge
just kept letting him take the knee and
get back up and take the knee pull it
back up but similar to that then do you
know how well the referees knew each
fight because that I I'd be interested
to know if the referee was told in this
fight you know it's obviously it's King
Kenny at the end where one of the
referees was literally like outside
filming JJ in the ring and I was like
bro come on have some respect I know
right and that's that's supposed to be
have special dignity you know yeah I
mean and I was like that's why you're
referee the way you did tonight no and
you're like you look like a fan who just
turned up right you know you it's the
the influencer boxing scene the
crossover boxing scene right so you know
some of these referees I'm sure are used
to you know rapping amateurs and maybe
low-level pros and even you know maybe
into the mid tier so they're used to
seeing let's be honest some of the
fights weren't very competitive like
Saul poppy went and starts to Andy
warski starched him right and so as the
card goes on seeing those fights happen
maybe you want to protect the guys
because you've just seen a guy there was
one moment in the night which really
rubbed me up the wrong way when I look
back at it when Kenny was uh really
rocked that's the big one he jumped in
so quick I mean it was like have you
ever seen Twilight where uh the guy
jumps in and saves her from the car
that's about a killer yeah it was like
that I was like me I bet you never
expected me to court twice
you watched it last night that's
incredible yeah
we all know why we watch Twilight guys
okay don't judge but the point I'm
making is he dived in there and saved
Kenny from what could have been and not
follow up yeah it could I mean he was
really in trouble I mean he literally
stopped since he's right hand from
Landing a stone like if if we were
talking about a real Pro fight there
which this is supposed to be yeah you'd
be accused of match fixing at that point
it was so out of order and it's not that
I want Kenny to get hurt no no no but
because it went to the judges it was a
big factor and ended up being a big
factor that was a big factor because you
give Kenny that time to recover which in
a normal fight wouldn't have happened
right I know and that's why I say you
know because the fight right before them
or I think so was it's all poppy and he
had Andy wobbled and followed up with
two more as he was was going into the
ground and Annie went snoozeville right
and I don't know this so I can't I can't
confirm or anything like that but maybe
a referee's seeing that and be like holy
[__] these guys are not mashed well at
all right and the next fight Sensei
wobbles Kenny in 10 seconds 15 seconds
and he's like [__] here we go again you
know and maybe you wanted to jump in
there before it got bad again but again
I agree it you know you can't jump in
there because now you're talking about
and this was something I didn't quite
understand and I do want to say this
Kenny and we'll talk about this fight
but can he performing the way he did it
puts him in a tough spot because
everyone's pointing the finger at Kenny
like oh you robbed us you you so it
happens again it's not his fault at all
completely not his fault when I came
back from outright so I came up from the
toilet oh yeah I yeah because I'm like
uh good job well done Sensei yeah and
they were like you don't have to do the
post fight interview I'm like well I
don't need you anyway because I know
who's won I'm gonna toilet come back I
see Wade's face right I'm like what's
wrong with you and you're like
and then they try to move on and to the
next fight and I'm hold up hold up hold
up what if I what have I just been told
here I was like Kenny was great there's
no he fought valiantly and he really dug
deep right there was just no way in my
opinion he won that fight and it there
was two moments of any any real danger
in that fight both of them were Sensei
swinging the hammer yeah so this is the
way I saw it scored and this is what
apparently the judges told Kenny and and
Sensei I think they even showed him
cards this they said that when Sensei
rocked Kenny early and Kenny got a
standing eight that Kenny quote unquote
dominated the rest of the round and I I
watched that fight back last night in
the room and and again I Kenny's jab was
so amazing dominated
yes hold yeah so Kenny's jab was great
and it really did put sensei in a place
where he wasn't as aggressive as he
wanted no but let's be honest though but
then he didn't dominate a single rounder
no so yeah exactly one round so this is
a competitive fight right but two rounds
were more uh for one guy exactly so
that's where it's clear and that's what
I was gonna say and I watched the rest
of the first round I think Kenny throws
maybe four or five more punches and
since he parries three three or four of
them and he made he I think he got to
jab the body off but since he's also
coming back and it wasn't a lot of
activity after that point from Sensei or
Kenny right it was just Kenny on the
front foot and that pressure and ring
control and I think so much is given to
you Kenny took the center of the ring
but yeah I wouldn't even call it like I
wouldn't call that domination in any
relationship in that round I wouldn't
either and that's why I was like that's
got to be a 10-8 absolutely we go to
number two and I do think can he gets
number two I think that's his round
right and then we go to three uh and
again how he got number two was on his
jab he didn't throw his right hand he
was a kind of smart thing that he didn't
because Sensei the whole game plan we
talked about this off camera and he's
probably not gonna liked it I said this
but his whole game plan was he had seen
Tommy just never swing a left hand in
the in the in the Kenny fight and he
wanted to land that big left hook he
wanted to bait in Step boom and throw
over the top and Kenny never gave him
the opportunity because he got touched
in that first round he got rocked I got
to give credit because I did hear the
corner I thought Daley did a very good
job he was smart with his pressure man
bringing his brother back into the right
frame of my Indie was like innocent yeah
he knew what he needed we've you know uh
seen how family can be when yeah boxing
game and uh the advice he gave him was
solid he he got his brother in the best
hospital place to have a chance of
winning that fight yeah however I still
don't think that'll happen no no and I
was gonna say I think round three goes
to Sensei again he lands the more you
know damaging shots and I think again I
watched it last night I was marking
tallies down I think he outlanded him in
the third uh it was close though
obviously the jab was working for Kenny
and again I think a lot was given to
ring generalship but when we're scoring
boxing it was damaging wasn't it I touch
you exactly I touch you you don't touch
me or if we're both Landing who's
Landing more heavy shots who's damaging
more shots and then three or four we're
talking about ring generalship and
control right we're talking about and
we're not giving any Credence to
defensive responsibility where Sensei
the Jabs are coming but we're preparing
and slip and rolling under Jabs that
also counts as well right defensive ring
generalship is something that also
counts but round four toss-up honestly I
you go back there was not a lot of
activity and then that last flurry so I
could even see if you wanted to Kenny
four cool I think it was 3-1 maybe 2-2
but even with 2-2 the first round being
10 8 it has to go to sensei in my
opinion that's that's what I see I agree
uh it's it's clear again let's not act
like if anybody else is in there with
Sensei they don't go to sleep after that
right hand in the first no can you can
you show it a lot in his two fights and
he's picked hard fights to start off
with respect and that's the tough part
with Kenny too is you look at a guy like
salt poppy who is very talented he's in
there with and no disrespect to Andy but
he's never the guy that should have been
in there with him you're looking at Dean
the great who's very talented evil hero
was not ready for him
Kenny cannot get a fight where he can
just show his skill and that's what's
the most frustrating part is because now
you can't go backward right you've had
sensei
maybe you know what you know what you
could do now the temp fight's there the
rematch is there that seemed like the
reason he wanted to fight sensei in the
first place was to get back to temper uh
it's there now I've got to go so credit
account he's definitely improving
amazing it was it was a very those are
the fights that will give him the
experience that it when he does get
clipped in future he's like I've been
here before yeah he won't Panic next
time and it's actually going to make him
a much better fighter even though in my
opinion he's lost his first two fights
even though it was like one and one or
whatever yeah no Sensei I think he'll
kick himself because
um
I think he had the skills to get yeah to
finish he already is we talked about it
he said I just wish I was more active he
kept saying before the fight I won a war
but unfortunately and this is the
reality in my opinion
with all due respect
Sensei just isn't a nasty spiteful
fighter like a Jake Paul or a KSI he
hasn't got that in his heart he's he's a
lovely guy he's a great guy this is a
man who teaches uh martial arts kids you
know it's just not who he is so while he
has possibly some of the best skills in
the space yeah he just doesn't have the
the evil in him yeah to make it work it
was also that and and I I asked to say I
was like you know we talked you know I
wanted to be like in his friends like
what happened you know he was like
honestly like one of them the things was
Kenny's jab it was like it was really
hard to get around because he couldn't
see it and that was something he kept
telling me I couldn't see it he's like
in in The Temper fight Kenny showed his
jab it was like a little more forced to
try to get out to temper who's a longer
guy yeah you have to deal with that this
time he couldn't see that jab he was
afraid if he couldn't see his jab then
he couldn't see his right hand and I get
that and but I but I I can I can level
with you on that that Sensei it might
not because one he talked about it this
is probably his last one and now knowing
that he he was in there for that last
time maybe some of that was there in his
head to be like okay let's I've already
had my my score in the first round I
already got another one in the third
let's just you know I'm saying let's go
ahead and cut this way out yeah but that
war mentality wasn't there in my opinion
and you know who it was on the other
side was was Kenny was was you know
trying to force that action was trying
to get it done but it was just you're
taking on one of the better guys in the
scene one thing I want to say I spoke to
uh a good friend Adam Cottrell who works
for uh BT Sport yeah does the UFC stop
yeah yeah and he said that fight was the
eye opener of the night for whom he went
okay this is high school quite high
level yeah compared to what he had
expected
so well done the canyon Sensei for
basically gaining that respect for us as
a community to show here we got some
[__] really good guys here Kenny
whatever's next for Kenny is only in my
opinion only up because his stock went
up in my like I know people will you
know point the finger me like oh you
didn't his stock went up in my opinion
like it's only up from here because he's
taken two fights that no one else would
take and now he's the guy I guarantee
you this he's the guy that no one will
want I guarantee that and that's what
I'd like to say you say yours not say
mango Soul puppy versus Kenny I was
gonna say slim uh
because I feel like you give him a
winner right because even if he lost
this one
you can't go backward you can't give him
anywhere I feel like no KSI ksi's next
fight should be either slim or sold
puppy I feel like why don't we talk
about that one do you know who I would
like her to be slim because a slim will
top that [__] yeah let's talk about the
slim fight yeah
um whereas salt pop a I don't know if he
can bring like if so so puppy the thing
about him his selling point is his hands
deadly like I think he I mean he does
this for no for a reason I think he
might be oh man I think he was the most
like wow oh yeah last last night it was
like the oh [__] like you are a problem
and if he did that to Kenny that's the
point where I'm like I don't care if he
can talk [__] or not a JJ
whereas in the meantime I think slim
slim can sell slim can sell the fight
and that's what we we didn't have anyone
who's gonna poke his finger in JJ's
chest and give him something back and be
like you ain't catching up to me you're
not on my level all that slim is so good
at that
it's the mental Dynamic of that as well
I think JJ's had Joe Weller straight
straight man uh Logan Paul straight
definitely a straight man uh and he then
he's had petrol and then he's had two
guys who are probably the straight guy
in the the relationship bear between the
two of them yeah and they're always the
guy so he calls himself he was always
the wild [__] the Wild guy the
guy who was together unpredictable you
didn't necessarily know where he was
going to come from he was the one who
was talking [__] more than the other guy
or the better [__] or the stuff that you
knew was getting into people's heads put
him up against slim and then see who's
the who's almost like the stranger one
out of everything through this willing
it's like putting him up against the
Joker yeah it's like who's more willing
to go to that weird place and be like
then we'll bring it out of him and
that's the point and also slim is a real
test like that knocked out on on Timber
yeah wow you know what so if you want to
talk about that fight I I was obviously
watching it there's a clip of me and
Rahman Jr I was sitting that has them
almost all night which I don't know if
you guys saw this but he was trying to
get at your boy Logan all night really
yeah I don't know if you I think he saw
the taste of the money he's like yeah
yeah I think yeah he wanted he wanted to
I think that's a mistake though Logan
had some words in him yeah and on the
same Journey as yeah I think they're on
yeah I would say Logan go do WWE do what
you're but that was what he was saying
but anyway him and I react to it we're
about to just run into the ring we're
like oh you know because slim with the
with the knockout but what I saw in that
fight was one this is what Wiley
temper's coach told me after the fight
he goes we were sitting there watching
Sensei and when Sensei you know he
didn't get the nod he's like Tommy's
whole body just went
like flush like he was just completely
zoned out like he lost interest in
everything he was doing at that point in
the locker room right and that can
really happen you see a teammate go out
there and get starched which since they
didn't but still the the unfortunately
we've seen people like potty and Molly
yeah yeah
it can lift you but you can hurt and
Tommy said he's like I'm never turning
the TV on again in that room like it
just it messed with me so much he's like
I just came out cold I didn't feel like
I was on Rhythm at all and you could see
he didn't look like his timing was there
at all but that also has to do with slim
Slim's a complex guy and what slim was
doing to Tommy that a lot of guys can't
do to Tommy because he's so tall was he
had enough range to get inside on Tommy
right and it was something you know jab
put his head in his chest but after the
exchange where either we were in the
clinch and separating or where Tommy was
just not necessarily his hands weren't
in the right spot the things that Tommy
does well by basically kind of Klitschko
uh you know job get a hold of him yeah
you know get my shots off and then the
break right he would stick his head in
his chest and Kenny did some of this
stuff to Tommy too but he just wasn't
long enough to get to him and he throws
the big over right hand and she Clips
Tommy on the chin and then Tommy wants
to have that little war inside because
he won those exchanges with Kenny when
he came forward right Kenny would throw
Tommy two three four after this time
slim would throw Tommy comes back slim
throwing two three four after and that
fourth one puts him down nuts not
knockout as well all week in the lobby I
had him in the face to face uh I did the
face to face in the lobby and all week
anytime there are teams around each
other slim says Tommy Tommy I'm about to
catch your body just messing with him
the whole time and that's what we
haven't never seen even with Logan yeah
Logan was never as as rightly said Logan
was never that confident yeah like to a
point where slim is very good at putting
that out yeah and slim will convince you
like he slim started to convince me I
was like dude
I've seen it and I'm starting to to kind
of turn here because not because like
temper's not confident but because slim
is just this two weeks notice Uber
confidence coming out and he's finishing
everything everyone yeah and that's the
thing is like
I said it last night he is he became a
superstar yeah based on
what JJ showed and what slim showed it's
so difficult to imagine who's the better
guy right now because of who they were
fighting against but I I wouldn't be
surprised if slim was like a it's a
challenge but well in terms of betting
odds he he was maybe not favorite but
highly better on in that fight because
he is just
the build up alone I I want to say that
I really want to say it yeah yeah no Liz
that's the fight KSI who did case I call
out you said slim uh then he went to
Tommy Fury and a couple of this that's
probably like he's always got a yeah oh
you're you're boy you know you're always
they want the human trafficker
I mean I don't know why he basically
went down a list of names I like that
though he had a bit of a shopping list
yeah yeah yeah you know who else he said
was was kind of shocking your boy Gibb
or the winner well you said the winner
and that was like you know what though
interesting you know what
I know they've spoiled that there's a
lot of times yeah but this
well I want to leave that to you because
I don't know as well like is that
something that's even realized it's just
the thing about Gibb yeah to me
I don't think he should let
friendship stand in the way of what he's
capable of right and if that is
it's a tough line if if JJ said look I
want the winner next yeah to me if if
you'll give how much money you're gonna
make out of that and it's also an all
that's that storyline is the only
storyline that maybe becomes surpasses
Slim Right Where it's like friends
become yeah and that's part of it is is
always like I think there's a bit of a
there's a slight stagnation in the story
lines at the moment between people you
almost need to switch it up a little bit
at the top level I know there have been
friends that have fought before like was
one of the early cards that we did there
were like people who knew each other
relatively well but it's much better if
you've got these two guys who are more
like brothers almost like you said the
storyline the back history of it and if
it's Austin McBroom
easy money because yeah like I said they
asked me at the end of the show who
would you like to see much yeah I said
Austin McBroom at the time because he's
such a bastard like you know the
scamming people all of that he is such a
perfect bad guy right and I think he JJ
would hate him yeah he would actively
really dislike him yeah yeah and that's
where the it would boil yeah but that's
where and I get that
I I've seen that or I've seen elements
of that and that's what makes me more
curious to see slim for Gabe or someone
else other side just to switch it up
also because you know again with this
influencer thing they tend to want to
keep the influences especially at the
very top level in their comfort zone
yeah just get the bag let's just make
sure this goes let's put people you know
if we're talking about being Athletics
here yeah we're talking about something
where let's put some competition yeah
like let's do some experimentation with
this don't make this just about and I
get last night was very much an
influencer event the kind of people who
are in the room but they were handling
belts Outlaws and that means that
there's a division there has nothing
right that there's rankings and that
means that there's moments where
you know people are gonna have to just
fight each other if you want it to be
legit and you want to turn this into
something
that's respectable maybe
hierarchy I see what you need if you're
gonna have belts competitive hierarchy
right yeah I do Wonder though yeah I
wonder how well it like influences deal
with that or how well the people in this
space deal with being ranked like that I
already know that some of them will
watch that showback and be slightly
pissed at me for what I said oh yeah and
unfortunately that's they have to
understand that like I'm part of the
show I was gonna say I'm not this is
impersonal yeah I'm not talking about
your character generally as if you're a
bad person right I'm literally judging
about your preparation and execution
it's not personal the old rule is hard
to do that because as a man yeah men
whether you're going to take a lot
personally well we're like we judge
ourselves on how we do a few things in
life and fighting tends to be one of
them and if someone says that wasn't
very good I get it but unfortunately if
they want me they're going to get me
being honest but that's kind I
personally I feel like that adds to it I
feel like it adds to the narrative it
adds to the story I think that the real
there are a few things that you need to
acknowledge in the influencer space that
are not actually conducive to good
boxing first of all in the influencer
space you own your own channel no one
else really tells you what to do with it
really right so you can pretty much
write your own narrative your audience
pretty much believe whatever it is that
you say yeah you know what I mean you
say hey this is how the fight went and
you know we see this yeah you know ksi's
audience say ksi's review after we do
this podcast is actually I thought two
legit guys and and maybe it will be and
fine and he goes I fought two legit guys
I proved myself on the night and anyone
who says otherwise [__] them yeah you'll
see people's watch this podcast and go
nah [__] you you're a KSI hater blah
blah that gets in the way of it being a
good boxing space first of all secondly
you've then got they're not really used
to being in real competition very often
you should exist in your own bubble
online boxes can't exist in their own
bubble really they have to dip into each
other's worlds it doesn't work like that
in but boxing either right well you have
fight camps and sometimes in MMA we've
seen teammates fight but it is right but
you know what I mean very rarely do you
like you know the last time we saw it
was like tea
whatever it was versus uh PewDiePie and
those guys were racing and those things
what I mean is actual competition yeah
right because you can also look at KSI
and go and like you know I'm sure there
are plenty of influences out there that
go well if I'd have had that start I'd
be on 20 million Subs yeah but I'm on
four million so I'm doing just like you
can justify all these things boxing is
literally just about did you outbox that
guy or not yeah and I'm kind of it makes
it a bit Messier almost because very
rarely do you see that in the influencer
space influencer put face to face Head
to Head you know the only other place
that really happens is in the [__]
makeup game where those guys are all
gaming yeah where they want to where
they want to rip each other's heads off
but gaming you can kind of go ah the
game was fixed or the earlier podcast
scene sure I mean that's yeah that's
nasty [__] um the nasty of us all of
them is definitely the makeup one but I
feel like boxing will come a closer the
mega one yeah we need to get some makeup
influencers in the Box absolutely double
competition I want James Charles versus
that um the other Jeffrey Jeffrey that's
what I want get pink gloves on oh yeah
now we're talking hey right yeah make
money in that huge money in there you
call it the battle of the palace just
have a bunch of screaming
you call it malice on the pallets yeah
that's brilliant that's brilliant nice
work and out of that then you know we
basically get JJ I want a full house at
the start of that fight and whoever's
makeup's the worst is the loser yes
exactly yeah and then after that just
fits make it happen if you want to be a
misfit that's a misfit that's a misfit
like so you know by the way if you do
end up doing that we need 10 of whatever
happens at least 10 but no I think it is
I think that the competition and us
having to you know I don't even say
remain unbiased but it's the Joe Rogan
rule right it's you say what you see and
that is literally it right you can't but
sugar how many times over the years to
Rampage Jackson and other Fighters get
the whole uh the hoof with him I know
because and that's the game what I'm
saying is look any of them out there who
are upset at what I've said
you got to deal with it because you're
getting in the ring and if it's not me
saying it it'll be somebody else saying
it at the end of the day if you if and
and this is the fighter mentality right
you're like you said everything's you're
gonna take it personally but and it's
one of those things like what a dad
would say to a kid listen to what I say
not how I say it type of thing like but
also prove me wrong then if you think
I'm wrong right the next guy you fight
show me that you don't have to principal
scanner and I was gonna say you don't
have to agree with with everything that
you or I or anyone says right it's just
we are doing the job that we have to do
to make sure that this thing remains
legitimate at least in some fashion we
were trying we were trying can I ask you
this then oh by the way they wrote a
little article about something I said
about the um two in one night thing oh
in the mirror yeah it makes crude
comments JJ two in one night make it
crude it was also announcement
journalism school for you prick oh no
honestly do you know what I mean they're
saying a pro boxing night yeah I mean
I'm gonna make jokes yeah yeah they're
working on the Showbiz desk it's 1am and
they're literally watching back through
and they're like did he say something
that might be vaguely sexual there I
think we can make an article on it it's
weird though why don't we do this why
don't we talk about uh fights okay the
fights why don't we talk about KSI we
haven't really talked about it like what
he looked like in there we've talked
about Pineda we talked about swarms but
you know it's been three years right I'm
conducting this now interview um yeah go
ahead so it's been three years right
first impressions as he's now back what
do you think I was an athlete I was very
impressed I thought you look extremely
fit strong push-ups clapping push-ups
but this is the party okay uh next fight
I don't want to say no clapping better
not have that kind of energy yeah
because if you have the other guy's not
well not level yeah
um
some very good body shots
um he can crack to the body I've seen I
I literally was looking through the
robes and I'd seen that Pinhead on it
yeah squinting like he was not enjoying
that right
um I think um his hooks look good yeah
but I thought his shot selection and
this is literally the the day after
right I haven't watched it back yeah I
remember thinking your shot selection
you could be setting these up better
yeah like what sold puppy did he really
set that moment up so easily so quickly
I think he made hard work of it because
not because he couldn't get them out
there quick enough he just didn't pick
his spots adequately and my main thing
is if someone is running away
tough you wanna you wanna close the
distance but get your job going yes
things up behind the job yeah and I felt
like he was just in kill mode and any
boxer and I even uh Vidal Riley in one
of his uh fight the first fights back
after that long layoff once he had him
hurt without tensed up and was really
trying to get him out of there JJ did a
similar thing yeah so this isn't some of
the high level Pros don't do he did a
similar thing yeah so all I was all I'm
thinking is it's good that he's got the
cobwebs off but next time
he has to think more yeah I think it was
a little too emotional in there
um and not enough playing right boxing
player your game right right there
wasn't there was a there was a uh it's
like an old saying you know you want to
walk the dog around that ring right you
want to be able to to lead guys where
you want him to go and that is off your
jab right and you said shot selection is
something I really I I thought as well
like multiple times especially in the
Pineda fight I think he fell in love
with the overhand right a lot right he
fell in love with that big shot that he
lands on everyone it's a cracker right
he's a shot he can land it but but when
you want to see when you're telegraphing
it and I was gonna say it was yeah it it
makes the I mean everyone to hurt the
guy so much less because he's like well
I know what's coming every 40 000 yeah
yeah every time that that's why it's all
poppies was so good because the guy
didn't say come because he moved him and
then came with the other hand there's
being able to frame someone like I said
just push them where you want them to be
and and also too you know with KSI and
like you talked about with guys being
such novice guys in there it's almost
harder to get the leash on them to walk
them around right because they're not
moving like a normal body they're not
coming towards you no that most
knockouts happened because the guys walk
on right yeah or because you've seen a
familiar tendency or you've seen an
ability for yourself to go oh I can
capitalize on things the Swarms the
Finish Line
swarms is actually running away and he's
doing spins and running the final punch
lands I mean he's he's moving away he
didn't even cut swarms flush there no
and the referee was just like nah [__]
this I don't know if KSI caught to the
body he had some really nice shots I
don't know if he caught Pineda or swarms
with that flush right hand no no he
didn't the fact that he didn't I think
says work to be done yeah like
ultimately
we were going to compare this to Jake
Paul because he's made this all about
Jake Paul yeah and I think
this is if I was to say what what kind
of fight is this like maybe it's a bit
disrespectful to Ben askren but in terms
of Ben astron's hands they're not good
but the difference was is Ben came
forward yeah which enabled Jake to
annihilate him whereas these guys just
had no interest in doing that and I
think it is so hard to judge JJ but I
think it if brutally honest I expected a
little better
but I think had he had a better opponent
we would have seen better I think it's
fair can I ask you a question what do
you think JJ's thinking today post fight
because we've all had that moment in our
life where you know what youth in your
mind it goes a certain way and the
adulation comes your way and it's like
oh yeah this is going to be really good
and then you do it and it doesn't quite
work out or that the human reaction in
the room or the fight just doesn't go
how do you think he's feeling about that
honestly I feel like that today from
even just for myself not because I was
like oh you know I didn't do it's just
one of those things where you have that
that post fight pull back to reality
where you're like ah did I do everything
I wanted to do did I was I as good as I
could have been on that night I have
that every time I've done Creator Clash
included when I was like ah did I did I
really go out and smash it and I think
there's going to be a little bit of that
there's a little bit of that especially
with I guess when you're you know you're
building up a fight you're never going
to go well you know obviously this guy's
gonna run away from me no I'm going to
chase him around the ring but therefore
there becomes this psychological side
where he's built it up and built it up
and then do you think he feels a little
anti-climax
I don't even know if it's because of you
know his quote-unquote performance but I
think just because of the moment itself
right you build for so long
yeah makes it slightly on yeah climately
for him I guess but I wonder what the
people around him are saying that
because that can have a massive
influence and
um of some of the things I was hearing
look I remember seeing uh Bazinga uh
yeah yeah yeah so he beforehand I've
seen a little clip of him going I expect
him to wash these guys no problem yeah
so the fact that
people in his immediate circle were
saying similar things to me means okay
the expectations were roughly the same
in his friendship group is what I had
right so hopefully like people are just
you know always honest with them but
it's his boxing coach that I think uh is
most important and has to be uh has to
be it'll be interesting to see what you
know it's obviously everybody knows
Alexis over at shoot Fighters he's been
in the game for a long time now trains a
lot of MMA guys trains a lot of Muay
Thai guys and some boxers right let's
not forget he did train Derek chazora
for the uh the USIC fight it was with
David last night yeah yeah yeah
terrifying man oh my gosh as soon as he
walked by I was like no one give this
man a table it's going in the air if you
give him a table he said you look like
Tyson Fury you're like Hey listen I
don't know don't get me confused yeah no
because I know what you want to do Tyson
Fury let's just leave that yeah forget
that um I'll be Tyson furry right now
I'm like how do you make that way
because I weigh like so much more than
shizora no and also yeah David Haye he
had him for a long time so he's well
versed and I'm sure like you said I'm
sure he's honest with KSI and I think
the thing that they'll take away from
this is they can be proud of the work
they put in to get to this point just
like anybody else that's been off for
years right when you have that work to
get to that point okay maybe you're not
the most polished you want to be yet but
that's what these next couple fights are
for because even KSI after the fight you
interviewed I mean Jake Paul's name was
not mentioned right he wasn't like a
give me Jake next yeah I think that's a
smart move he's quite there yeah and I
think he knows that yeah and there's
nothing by the way nothing wrong with
that let's let's go back at three or
four years when KSI beats Logan and Jake
didn't want that fight exactly you know
I mean everyone has to have things gotta
have that balance so it's it's Jacob
that's just the worry that's the worry
you've got Wembley Stadium yeah you've
got an insane amount of money that can
be made by these two men yeah the
problem is do we get there do we even
get that fight yeah because as we've
seen with uh Connor Ben and Eubank Jr
they made a fight in a rush because they
were like one of us could lose yeah all
of this is not quite as special yeah and
with tricky Fighters like solid pop ear
and slim and the winner of McBroom and
Gibb JJ has quite a few options that are
going to be difficult that could mean he
may lose a decision or something right
something could go wrong right something
can go wrong is the point so they kind
of need to make those steps no I I want
to yeah I know I know what you're gonna
say they need to make those steps but
they need to make them carefully and
quickly they need maybe one or two
fights more each yeah that they win and
then make the fight in the summer of uh
2023 in my opinion my only argument
against that and I think you're kind of
right sometimes I do and I've been
thinking this the whole time I'm not I'm
not really a boxing guy like I enjoy
watching and I've definitely I developed
a taste for it because of you but I
don't know you know I've not grown up
with it
the only thing the only difference I see
with this is boxing people go they think
of belts they think of routes to get to
belts they think of ways to get to
places this isn't quite the same thing
and I don't think you're wrong but I
think sometimes it's more we it's more
we so it's like if if JJ loses people
almost want to see him have to reach
even further to get together so here's
the problem for me and then Jake can
play on it's the Mystique right right
now okay yes let's say JJ has an
astounding
um performance against a slim yeah
finishes him Flatline yeah what if you
win Jake Paul does the same to Anderson
Silva right right that fight just
becomes more compelling it becomes
bigger because then they're both looking
so good and they're not but the more
weaknesses one shows the less Intrigue
there is for this fight which is why
given JJ's opponents last night I am
concerned as to who is selecting these
who is managing his way to a Jake Paul
fight because that is not something you
can learn on the Fly and I know moms is
involved but I don't know what I'm sure
um
and also the subtle was it the brothers
darling yeah
um so
this is a careful operation that they
need to execute because there is
potentially 100 million dollars pounds
whatever yeah each you're talking about
the minimum right yeah this could be the
biggest Payday 2 million pay-per-views
it could easily yeah a YouTuber has ever
received it and Jake and JJ that is why
more than and I know it's it's you know
money's money or what but but this is a
different level of money than even they
are used to and I can say like Jay could
lose his next fight and you could still
make that fight that's the one like if
KSI loses I don't know you know you
can't lose the slim and make a joke but
it's also I think to go along with that
though is just that JJ has to win his
last fight before he faces Jake
I think they both have to yeah yeah but
I think KSN needs multiple I don't think
we need one right maybe two more at
least two do you mean legit convincing I
mean like YouTuber per like boxer next
right and if he does away with whoever
we do got to step into the you know I
don't want to say the same Arc Jake went
into but it needs to be that next if you
said to me what's it what's a dream yeah
scenario right Brian what's a dream
scenario Lawrence yeah right we've got
slim yeah a bit slim so we're just we're
putting it out there it's slim I I think
I think slim just because of what he
brings to the table as a full package
slim self happy whatever yeah I think so
poppy his hands are lethal but I think
slim brings us to sell everything he
makes it entertaining yeah then
a Tommy Fury maybe yeah I can see that
if he beats Tommy the Intrigue of a Jake
Paul is is enormous uh then so there's
there's the road map for three fights
and then Wembley yeah no I I that's and
I know JJ is already talking about
January he's just come back yes that's
six months uh so I easily can get you
know the ring rust that he he had that's
gone or at least you would think
somewhere gone the next six months go
back and sharpen
and Logan said he would like the Box on
the car on the card yeah in January now
that is interesting because who do you
give him I have no idea yeah maybe the
the uh you know your boy over in Romania
I don't know yeah
I still left in his little box is always
what we're calling Rumble listen I don't
even think it's that I mean I I just
actually think the interest is gone you
think
the five minutes of fame are over no one
cares yeah so moving on put him in his
box see ya can I can I actually say one
thing and I thought it was really smart
and it kind of worked and we didn't
quite work out why they don't do this
more
from the very beginning yeah that we
looked up I didn't even know there was a
third deck okay that's the idea uh it
could be McBroom versus Logan AJ versus
Slim oh vice versa right right but the
point is is get them both if McBroom
beat Gibb obviously which I'm rooting
for Kevin I really believe kid will win
that fight yeah yeah but just because
McBroom is such an [__] to people
yeah you know I mean he makes a good bad
guy it's so tough to match like if he
isn't awesome I've just been told no no
that way I don't know
because I don't know him personally but
everyone that's gone with him it's the
business like the move it just seems
like everyone gets screwed over by it
kind of the thing is from this from the
story I see on like the ace family thing
I want him to be a nice guy it seems
like you yeah yeah just like the one
like there's nothing there is boxing
time well he's a natural athlete too
right he's the guy that you know we talk
about Logan and we talk about Jake being
natural he's the same one he played
college basketball and I've seen some of
his stuff he's not he wasn't a bad
basketball player yeah well we know
basketball players don't always make the
best possible that's true that's true
but he has taken the time to actually do
it I still hold on to the fact that Nate
didn't Spar leading up to the Jake fight
you know what Nate did do he came
forward and he was in shape yeah yeah
and made it a little tougher than it
should have been for Jake because he was
like I can't the point is is the
Highlight Reel not okay
yeah and that's what these are the
they didn't have the balls basically to
do what Nate Robinson did so shout out
Nate Robinson shout out hey man two-time
slam dunk chance that's the real thing I
don't have any other way is there any
other uh fights that we should be
talking about here I mean we do have yes
October coming up no whoa whoa whoa
sorry neither of you actually mentioned
deji anyway
podcast okay so that she was a
performance of the night for me it has
to be for me because because of where he
was yeah to where he is right because
everyone had told me I talked to Leon I
talked to Vidal I didn't talk to KSI I'm
like what am I not seeing here like why
is it in this last time because I see
little bits I see flashes and they're
like bro in the gym he is doing this to
guys in the gym all the time it's like
when we get that next kind of transition
to the people in the main event it just
doesn't come out his mood it came out
this time his mood was so different all
week all week when fousey was so intense
and you you even said to me yeah when we
were off come it was like maybe it's a
little too intense like is he too riled
up too emotional that she's like okay
I'm gonna throw hands and the difference
was this time you know deji had heard
and the Alex you know build up
everything everyone had said about him
and he was very cautious about saying
something that was going to get him in
trouble should he lose this time it
didn't feel like that it felt like deji
wasn't talking because he didn't feel
like he had to right he was like I know
what I'm about to do you know what I
mean that was the difference not I don't
want to talk because I'm scared of
what's going to happen if I do I just
don't it's like failing your driving
test like a few items or whatever
forever it's like the nerves are gone
now because he knows what it feels like
experience is experience whether it's
good or bad you've been in there you've
seen it you've seen the worst of the
worst it can't get worse right unless
you just get it's flat line but he'd
seen it and so this time all he had to
do was correct little things here and he
had the he managed the fight well one
thing I will say is when I watched a
little bit of the highlights I remember
thinking
you're taking your little breathers with
and Vidal always told me about this
early on he was like you gotta breathe
within the rounds sometimes and catch
those little breaks to recharge him he
managed to fight and fuzzi for all he
was super fit coming into it you
wouldn't have known it yeah because he
didn't manage to fight any it was the
same thing he walked right for which I
thought he would and I thought honestly
wasn't a terrible strategy but he
started chasing deji around he was just
walking right into him and snaking back
and forth and what deji did good and
kind of similar was go back to the
Vinnie fight he came out like a rocket
right trying to take Vinnie out but this
time he did it under control like you
said he caught his breath in moments in
the clinch
relax shake the arms out wait wait then
explode right it was four five take some
time off one two first deal so if if I'm
being brutally honest I think um very
impressive shape coming in I do give
them credit and also his post fight
interview actually like got me yeah yeah
that's how you lose yeah you took it
like a man you gave your credit you said
what this means to you yeah it kept it
moving I really respect that that's why
in in the Panera uh and and the Swarms
fights I was disappointed with that they
didn't just do what they should be doing
in there as you know you signed up for
this you know so I credit him for that
but the one thing I will say is hand-eye
coordination it's just not there for you
guys some people you're just not going
to be a boxer
no no yeah very passive aggressive it's
just not sometimes though it no matter
how much you work on it you'll get you
know incrementally better yeah but if
your hands and your feet and your hips
and your shoulders don't agree with you
you know it's just not going to get
together like it's like dancing it
really it just cannot dance and me I was
blessed with it I got caught tried out
last night too I was you know Slim's
walk out you know what I mean A Thousand
Miles I was giving it a little
watching this and just being like this
is how you make yourself into a
character right 100 they're so boring
they're yeah I'll take anyone next for
me or a man I know call people out be a
character [__] you did though dad you
said Bryce all next what do you think is
a great fight gotta be it man screw it a
minute put him in a main event yeah he
just became I think that might happen
Daddy just became the Superstar people
wanted him to be for so long
for me I mean undefeated I have a thing
where I feel like I can
um I get a read on people I get a feel
for people very quickly and with for
years with deji I've been up and down
there's been times where I'm like what a
lovely guy yeah and there's been times
where he kind of becomes His Own Worst
Enemy and I get and I've been frustrated
by that and his attitude Awards me and
other people there's just been a little
bit off sometimes but the other idea he
was so in a kind headspace I could feel
like he was at peace with himself he
wasn't this like this character that
he'd been in the past which is uh
rubbing people up the wrong way yeah he
was just full of kindness and he just in
the perfect headspace and now I think
like okay
you're gonna be the guy that you want to
be right as a man like and I'm not
talking about boxing even I'm talking
yeah
you know you have those moments and I
had it where my ego was getting in the
way of who I who who I can be because
I'm too busy worrying about people's
opinions of me and I'm no doubt that
dead she's probably gone through a bit
of that when you've lost a few fights
people are talking [__] but he just
seemed in a great place in his life
think about it yeah think about how
young deji is too man like he's becoming
a man right in front of everyone's eyes
just like ASI did just like Logan Jake
all those guys he was even younger he
was younger and now he's becoming that
age where people forget I don't even
know how old he is but he can't be past
25 right I just wanted to be about 25
yeah so it's just now coming into that
age where he is you know developing all
of these things that he's had around him
and he's seen and he's like I said he's
becoming the person that he's
comfortable with and I think that's the
biggest difference I saw when I was
sitting next to him at the presser just
interacting with him he was just himself
he wasn't trying to put on something for
me because I'm the YouTube boxing guy
and everything he says to me it's like
oh he must have better people around him
as well because I mean remember that
when he lost that fight against the
blonde kid I know uh the the group of
boxing guys I think sorry were they
boxing guys I thought they were just a
party house the traveling circus
but daily he gives a lot of credit to
and I think for a good reason he you
know deji will I think and I can
probably speak to a little bit of this
he trusts very few it seems like and
when he does trust you though like daily
like Leon like Calvin all those guys
that are now in his Camp it's like he
wants not only to do it for them and for
JJ and that but now they've engaged him
that friend of his at the end where he
was like Shane yeah I'm sick of you uh
losing yeah and uh we a lot of people
don't have those conversations the fact
that he's got someone in around him that
would say that is good did you see the
moment where his parents came back into
the dressing room I haven't seen that
it's a sweet moment it's worth watching
yeah it's nice you can see um the moment
at the end where the brothers Embrace
yeah I saw JJ in the locker room going
crazy didn't don't think he had any
pants on so I don't know if that was the
last shot to get but yeah it was jumping
up and down
is a boxer but no pants but uh
impressive yeah I was like hey you know
yeah nice shot he looked I mean you
could see how proudly on was yeah of
course so many people credit Leon with
getting them in into incredible shape
I'd love to know what Leon does with
people because yeah
the guy absolutely beats people the dude
power lifts tree trunks son and I get
that but but you know do you know what I
think about it is is and it's kind of um
assume that when you get a personal
trainer or someone like Leon then you'll
just do the stuff that that that guy
says right so many people get these guys
and deji's had a few people who've gone
listen we're going to work you hard and
they've let the guy get into terrible
[__] yeah yeah yeah it takes the person
to invest in Leon as well yeah and also
honesty and I think that's what Leon
brings it to that's one thing Leon's got
this energy which is he's quite a pure
guy do you know what I mean he's very
straightforward or [__] yeah and and
but also in such a positive way I just
really love to get into the room and I
kind of want to get in his head and see
how he gets this out of people because I
think there's a real skill in that like
that's a really valuable skill is to be
able to motivate someone to a degree to
end up even just looking like deji
because you remember what deji looked
like two fights ago yeah the body he had
all these kind of things so much heavier
and I get that but that's fine for an
everyday guy who's walking around
doesn't want to fight right I'm sure a
lot of people you know they go to work
and they look like that every day right
right that's fine but not if you want to
get in a ring and you want to you want
to be the opposite of that so I mean
credit to those guys for getting him
even there and credit to Leon for being
able to motivate people who have money
who have who can just go you know what I
give up I don't know let's just drop out
I'll say I'm gonna enjoy whatever they
he gets these guys to a very impressive
point in their lives I agree and then
daily too with with absolutely deji's
skill at her daily talk this week about
deji trying to be more canelo-ish and I
didn't know exactly what he meant until
I watched and it's a lot of like heavy
lean on the front foot heavy jutting the
chin forward draw out shots favorite my
favorite moment in the dead tree fight I
was looking through the ropes I wasn't
even watching them on I was no I never
came and I seen Dungey being like come
on yeah come on then I'll just bring it
wow just so he can wow
the timing to land a lead hook going
backward for a check is so hard to do
yeah and I've never seen deji even come
close to doing something like that and
then to land it plant boom uppercut
every he had everything
and for years Vidal told us that you may
be the mortality I had it yeah two
brothers yeah and we see an Evidence of
uh you know of how talented he is when
he's fully fit there is that was one
thing I was wondering why you were
sitting talking about the the fight or
the lead up to the fight of uh JJ versus
Jake
whether if deji
being as being the more talented brother
maybe on the B side but building himself
up has some sort of
say in there whether Jake sort of goes
Jake's got a bit of a sadistic side I
just wonder if he goes I'll take debut
first and then we'll see what happens
with KSI do you know what I mean because
if you're if you're if you're it's not
it's not an uncompelling matchup do you
know what I mean Jake does the two in
one night does you first
um I think it's gonna take a while
there was uh I was on the pre-show for a
minute with uh Joel
in the ring and there was a mention of
if they do Wembley KSI Jake Paul wow I
would take one of them I would like to
see it him or Bryce I think it's a
perfect matchup for deji to stay within
that build phase and see exactly where
his skills are but also not jump not
take that massive jump It's actually
cleans price out in uh two rounds you
know what man I will say Joe's a tricky
one because Joe's such a physical
specimen but last time he had no boxing
experience or not well the guy who was
training him wasn't Rice's Bryce is
gritty I will say and boxing skill I
understand it's nowhere near the level
that we would want to see him at I will
say this though Bryce is a former
wrestler he's a greedy guy and I would
want to see like we do with all these
guys that level from first fight to
Second uh Joseph I think about prices I
I really like him as a character in this
in this whole thing great [__] talk uh
funny guy brings out the the bad blood
and it says that but I think he's one of
those wrestlers who it does wrestle he
doesn't put together here but your great
Grappler just can't throw punches like a
our screen time I could be wrong though
uh we'll see maybe he's gonna maybe he's
training uh and I don't know about I
think Joe has more natural Talent than
Bryce either when I've seen Joe
um just doing little bits here and there
in the past few years I've been like you
know you should just if you want to do
this again just go for you get in a
boxing Camp ASAP yeah because I think he
has good potential and that fight sells
like it out here Joe Weller daddy that's
a huge that's a that's a you could mean
that you could make a paper view it not
even just you can pay-per-view you know
the the event we're talking about
starting the night
there you go put them put those two on
the side that feels I'm not joking yeah
it changed the night yeah because you
remember in the early fights there's
still this like people are still
filtering in yeah oh it's all right it's
just this guy versus this guy will we're
just there for KSI it was so packed they
they started they only opened the doors
30 minutes before the show was Parts
about to start headed to the latest show
20 minutes yeah that's how many people
were just flooding exactly and the O2
does this the O2 does this week in week
out so it's not like this is like
something where it's like oh I don't
know how many people are going to turn
up here maybe if they're sort of the
[__] tickets are probably they
wouldn't have that is a real problem I'd
love to see the next fight in real in
person
um one thing I want to cover before we
end uh well coming to the next event
yeah let's talk about that Vito Belfort
versus hassim Roman Jr you know who's
the sorcedra and quote unquote co-main
on that car is that um
back into the scene and I think he might
be a guy he's another one who I who I
could imagine in that deji Joe Weller
size yeah size and skill I've seen you
know he's been very Coy which is a good
thing in this scene you don't want to
give too much up because guys see it and
they're like [__] that one thing we
normally though after that game fight is
hot determined determination exactly it
ain't gonna be but skill I'm seeing now
yeah I'm seeing some you know there's a
little bit of stuff but I'm seeing some
stuff from Jay and I know like you said
he's already a gritty dude he's already
down to go and scrap it out and he's
slightly yeah yeah as well right no
that's true but yeah I think he would he
would he would do that but I don't know
the guy he's fighting yet I just saw
yesterday and I was doing the production
I haven't released
the fact that he's back yeah is a plus
for the YouTube and the crossover boxing
he's an amazing character anyway
this is this is for the for the real
fight fans out there you know Vito
Belfort an old MMA I don't want to say a
legend because I don't really without
without the sauce what do you have been
what he did to Michael Bisping the right
way for me yeah this guy was juicing
Bisping wasn't and it left pissing with
what with one eye yeah I mean because he
messed up rock all the same way like
there's a lot of guys that suffered from
trtv tour yeah this is and no doubt
we're gonna get trtv tour 100 absolutely
but the problem is he's in there with a
much bigger guy who's an actual boxer
and it will give Vitor his credit one of
the youngest at the time I think the
youngest UFC Championship 20 21 and then
Jon Jones was like Yeah hold my beer but
foreign
there were some guys that that he had
the fastest hands basically that we'd
ever seen in MMA Vitor was fighting when
you could still wear shoes in the
Octagon yeah where he was punching and
pair of clock with shoes incredible
stuff so yeah but he's been around you
know he's going to break him in the head
how's he said it it was wild times man
but he he's been around I think he
fought Tank Abbott too and messing it
yeah is he was a real special yeah like
yeah 19 20 years old yeah it was but
brutal hassim Rockman right a guy that
is a bridge await you know 220 plus
224-ish this is gonna be a tough tough
deal for and I know vitor's uh I know he
was talking about I still want to be a
world champion knowledge I was like I
think he's not I don't know what I don't
know what Hassan wants to do because I
think he has gotten a taste of what we
do over here in this in this influence
you mean money any yes of course but
he's actually not bad at the internet
side you know he's actually his press
conference with Jake was fantastic I'm
saying he's not taking anything away
from him I'm just saying I think there's
two roads right oh I guess he's trying
to go there let me get more famous I
think he's wanting to put across exactly
and jump the queue to get a belt that's
what I thought it is but the point is is
I don't think you will come once you
take the the red pill I don't see you
coming back which I mean you could argue
may not even be a bad choice for him but
it might not lead to the world titles
right it might just lead to like you
said The more money the more notoriety
Fame whatever but then at a certain
point big big dude yeah I'm don't get me
wrong I'll watch that Spa with uh Jake
and you know uh Jake had his moment Jake
did well but his moments but for a guy
that only been boxing for a year and a
half yeah at his moments you know and
and but on the other side I Sims like
okay that right hand cool nice what else
you got you know not really trying to
punch you like I mean hold this jab like
oh that's cute you know whatever I
really wanted to see that fight in a way
because they told it so well by that
that that's one of the few items where
who was the original fight he was
supposed to be having it was Tommy sorry
Tommy yeah that was one of the few times
where they changed your point I'm like
actually I'm Mooring I got more
investors yeah a lot of other people
didn't feel the same way as well this is
the name and yeah but because of the
skill the danger yes it went up so I was
like okay and I don't know this for sure
so guys don't quote me out there if I
get this wrong in other comments and be
like wait it was actually I think this
is going to be a short round fight I
think we're talking a four-rounder here
with how some Rockman and Vitor so
that's firing yeah I know Rutman will be
happy with that because I think that's
what he was talking about he was like oh
four rounds and veto is a sprinter so
and Vitor you know coming off the the uh
historic Victory versus uh Evander
Holyfield we all know maybe that was the
worst thing of all of the things that
we've witnessed because of I have been
one of the words this Holyfield might
have been one of the worst Holyfield
against trt Belfort no it wasn't good
the guy couldn't even take our body shot
no not even one I'm like it was he was
having trouble standing like without him
he looked like Ronnie Coleman in there
yes I'm like and it sucks man because
that's that's a Vander [__] Holyfield
we're talking about you know what I mean
one of the greatest by the way like when
people talk about Alexander yusuke now
what he's doing too but that was that
was that was wholly exactly that's who
they compare him exactly is he is he at
that level that's what I hate is the the
kids the younger Generations see that
and they might not do the effort to go
back and watch how good he was and be
like that's the guy this old whatever
what we were watching in that fight was
an old man who took way too much
punishment in his career and had no
shout out to shout out to Florida
commission once again yeah I think also
though like those guys that they realize
when people want to get in and get some
money right by the way
I I had a little word with one of the
commission guys
oh yeah I was like uh oh yeah yeah yeah
I was like at the way and I was like the
Swarms guy yeah I started boxing two
weeks ago uh
you sure about this it was like pasta
medical I'm like
cool okay yeah uh yeah he he proved he
was alive yeah we're good to go we're
good uh I I didn't realize it was going
to be like this you know but I think in
future I just hope that nothing bad
happens where a guy who has no matter of
days 14 days has been doing mainly
Weight Watchers yeah not not pods and
you know bag work yeah the day before
when he went when he did the weigh-in
immediately went to Weight Watchers
after and they went congratulations my
love that's three pounds this week
you've lost so give him a round of
applause
you're the Biggest Loser yeah no I think
you know hopefully that doesn't happen
because M12 like we have to obviously
acknowledge the fact that Alex
unfortunately had to be pulled out of
the fight and things like that happen
it's the fight game but it the
contingent again this is the first one
we learned from it the contingency plan
has to be let's have a backup contracted
ready for months but this is the thing
when swarms was announced that's what we
were told yeah he uh he came out and
he's always been that and I'm like and
he came out and said oh I had two weeks
to lose 11 kg and learn how to box he's
a runner he's a track star what about
the um my favorite my favorite guy and
the whole thing of this was the Nazi
yeah that was that seemed like some sort
of like weird little side
that was unfortunately that was another
example of the teething issues of this
event I think you know the fact that
people hadn't done their research and
someone had obviously thought he was he
was a tough like oh this is a tough guy
another again the marketing of a pro
boxer and you just
missed the white power there was like a
swastika so we gotta get a wide shot
yeah you know when you're doing the
medical and they go I'm just gonna put
this uh stethoscope on you just above
the white power I'm just gonna pop that
there yeah okay no he is alive good okay
it doesn't work positive medical yeah
that's the medical yeah yes that's the
point yeah no it was really AJ to fight
Hitler in the next fight it'd be
fantastic to be fair I'd actually I'd
love to see JJ beating the [__] out of
Hitler or any nuts I'm not
discriminating I wouldn't discriminate
unlike them I wouldn't discriminate oh
absolutely yeah
exactly so to speak
um I think we've uh We've chopped this
up nicely yeah boy it's been a good one
yeah thanks for coming on weird
appreciate you my pleasure fantastic uh
don't forget if you want to check out
the weird concept and all of the good
stuff he is doing I will put the link
for his channel in the description below
and I look forward to doing more work
hopefully with Misfit boxes yeah yeah if
they can sort my mates tickets out and
uh tell me not to get in my pants at six
o'clock the main the main piece of
feedback I would say is it did look like
you're a few presenters short so maybe
if you just want to yeah yes to me yes
put laws in the locker room yeah the
lads in their puns yeah yeah you'll love
that I mean as much as you did sure
that was the weird concept on true
Geordie podcast